[Music]
foreign good evening you're watching the
Press previewer first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive here at
the Sky News Center time to see what's
making the headlines with the columnist
and broadcaster Steve Richards we're
also joined tonight by The Daily Mail
columnist Sarah Vine thank you both for
staying up late and joining us uh
tonight they're going to be with us from
now until midnight this evening first so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages as they come in tonight starting
with the metro newspaper it splashes
with Prince Harry's claim that he once
found what he believed to be a tracking
device on his ex-girlfriend Chelsea
Davies car
the telegraph tomorrow leads on wishing
sunax visit to the United States it says
that he will tell President Biden that
the UK will take the lead in tackling
the threat posed by artificial
intelligence The Daily Mail focuses on
news that as of today 43 police forces
across the country say they've sent
officers to visit a hundred percent of
burgled homes
our press preview colleague people
Carrera has a scoop in the guardian
tomorrow reporting the Boris and Carrie
Johnson broke covered restrictions by
hosting a friend at Checkers to help
them plan their wedding on to the eye it
understands that the energy regulator of
gem intends to make suppliers compensate
customers for hidden charges that they
were forced to pay now the ft's UK
Edition is embargoed until midnight we
have the US edition for you though the
version pictures the heavy smog
currently blight in New York City of
course Mark Stone reporting on that a
few minutes ago here on Sky News and on
to the star as well for you it tells us
we don't necessarily have to fear from
swimming with sharks
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
that you're going to see on screen
during the program you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch with us well let's meet our
guests again tonight as I said we're
joined by Steve Richards and Sarah Vine
a very good evening to both of you I
know that you've been looking ahead to
what's happening in the papers and we're
going to start with the front of the
Metro tonight and of course their
coverage if you can imagine it would
always lead with Harriet that's exactly
what they've done
um Sarah take us away with this one
Harry's car tracker bombshell why do you
think they've decided to focus on this
particular line of questioning that the
the Prince Harry was under in the high
court today
I don't know because most of the
questioning is the problem with Harry is
that a lot of his responses to these
questions have actually been very vague
so in this case he says uh that he found
a tracker on his then girlfriend's car
Chelsea Davey
um and his sort of his explanation for
It is Well it happened to a friend of
mine therefore it must have been a
newspaper who did it that did it but the
problem is he needs to prove these
things you can't
you know you can't just say vaguely as
he has done you know I I'm I I think
this was happening I think this was a
this story was was obtained um through a
hacking an illegal hacking it's got to
be you absolutely got once you get to
court and you get in front of a
barrister you've got to be able to prove
what you're saying and I think the
problem that he's had over the last
couple of days is that he hasn't really
landed a killer blow
um to the mirror uh that you know he's
lots of speculation lots of things that
could you know could have been mistakes
could have been done wrong could have
been criminality but nothing really
seems to have come through as proof and
I think that this of the the Chelsea
Davey tracker thing is is a quite a good
example of that because it's it's yes it
it would indicate that somebody was
trying to follow him but the question is
who and I don't think he really has the
answer to that yeah just reading a bit
further into this uh into the how the uh
Metro have covered it Steve they say
that uh that that David Sherborne of
course that is the KC that the lawyer
for
um Prince Harry asked him or how did you
know and he said because we found it as
we as a friend had done to them in
London so that they did find the tracker
But as Sarah says they just don't know
who put it there
yeah and we could analyze the specifics
for the next 24 hours but I think what
is much more interesting is the broader
picture we don't have many troublemakers
in politics at the moment and we need
troublemakers I like troublemakers and
here is a troublemaker in capital
letters uh the royal family rarely speak
in public on anything other than a few
banalities and he has decided to take on
the media which is very Mighty in the
United Kingdom and I think it is
courageous he could have a much easier
life not doing this
um but he is and there's something quite
extraordinary about it it's kind of
Shakespearean on one level this Prince
and Exile coming back to a British Court
to take on the media and to be honest
the specific Sarah might be absolutely
right that nothing is proven but to step
back from that
what uh incredible Dynamic this is of
it's a lot to do with his mother
but most Royals when you think about it
I know they are revered on the whole
don't do things which are surprising and
interesting and whatever you think about
here this is surprising and interesting
and I think impressive
um yeah so what do you I mean do you do
you agree with Steve is this courageous
of Prince Harry it's definitely it's
become a life mission of his well I
think I think Prince Harry's psychosis
is as as Steve says he's very damaged by
his upbringing and what happened to his
mother
um but a lot of that is to do with his
his family and and the way his uh father
treated his mother and what happened
subsequently
um and Harry's focus is the media he
sees them as the villain of the piece
but it's more complex than that the the
problem I think a lot of people have
with Harry is that a lot of them people
do feel sorry for him I feel a lot of
sympathy for him for all of those
reasons but he's written this awful book
that he's published in which he is
basically doing to his family what he
accuses the Press of doing to him so you
know in the book he talks about how his
brother isn't as good looking as he used
to be in how his hair is all falling out
and then he talks about his father you
know taking his teddy bear from his
childhood he and he says he he gives
away all sorts of very personal private
things about his family which is
precisely the stuff that he claims has
damaged him so much so I think what
we're dealing with here is somebody who
is in a lot of pain very angry uh wants
to lash out wants to find a solution but
it's you know it's just much more
complex than that and the problem with
putting yourself in the courtroom like
that is that when you make these
accusations in the courtroom you have to
be able to prove them you can't just say
oh well I found a Tracker and because it
happened to amazing mine I assumed that
therefore this was happening to me
that's not good enough in a court of law
and he's put himself in that situation
and I don't think it's particularly good
for him I think whoever's advising him
whoever his friends are
need to try and stop him from doing this
to himself because he is I mean I think
yes it is it is fascinating and it is
interesting and all of those things but
it's not good for him apart from
anything else I mean ultimately you know
he is just ripping off us cat all the
time before before we move on one final
word from Steve on this and do you think
ultimately he will be successful Steve
quickly
well it depends what you mean by success
I mean I think it is
um uh I I it's all the things Sarah says
it's but it's also clearly or I've never
met the guy but he is evidently
genuinely shocked by the treatment of
some media Outlets towards him towards
his mother towards other people I know
politicians who are shocked but they're
too scared to do anything because the
parts of the media in this country are
incredibly powerful and intimidating
knowing all of that he has decided to
take them off now as I say it's
multi-layered but one of the motors is
that and I think the newspapers will
have to or you know whoever his targets
are will have to accept that part of it
is them and he is sincere about it now
whether he wins this or not who knows
but I think it is a sort of impressive
thing to do given that he could just
have an easy wealthy affluent life
wherever he chooses to be instead he's
got a project and it is the same
extraordinary okay we're gonna we're
gonna talk about it in a lot more detail
in the 11 o'clock hour so we'll park
that for now and and let's get some more
papers out the way as well they're
starting with the front page of the
telegraph interesting enough I don't
really talk too much about Prince Harry
they've got a picture of the Princess of
Wales instead on their front page read
into that as you will and they lead
heavily on the visit with British sunak
in the United States as we've been
leading here on Skies as well apparently
the headline reads that he's going to
tell Biden the UK can lead on AI it's
going to Britain will take the lead on
tackling the threat posed by artificial
intelligence which is tonight's going to
tell Joe Biden um tomorrow how do you
think this is going to go for him Sarah
um well I I don't know because you never
know with Joe Biden whether he's sort of
alive or not or listening but the fact
is that I mean sunak is right to try and
take the lead on it he wants to have a
he wants to have a an organization a bit
like the atomic energy organization
that's basically in charge of making
sure that AI doesn't get out of control
or that it isn't that it isn't so
unregulated that we I mean one of the
big issues over the last 10 15 years has
been the internet and and it's and it's
sort of the way it's taken over its life
our lives but it's completely
unregulated and I think the idea is not
to make the same mistake with AI which
could have much more far-reaching
consequences
um there's a lot of scaremongering at
the moment about AI you know the debate
a lot of people think it can do a lot of
good A lot of people are terrified that
it's going to we're all going to turn
into you know uh the Terminator so I
think the most important thing is to try
and have some sort of Regulation and I
think uh for Rishi Zuna lead the way on
this is quite a good idea I know that
the cabinet are quite divided over this
because half of them think that AI is
great because it can make everything
more efficient in government and then
the other half are a bit worried about
the Terminator aspect of it so I think
it's something that needs to be
discussed and it needs to be openly
discussed and it you know there needs to
be a proper convention about it we can't
just bury our heads in the sand and
we've had Elon Musk and various other
people saying the whole project needs to
be paused until we've got a handle on it
so I think his it's good that he's
responding yeah um Steve Sarah mentioned
scare mongering that the telegraph
themselves says it comes just days after
one Mr sennak's top advisors warned that
AI could kill humans I wipe out Humanity
within two years unless action was taken
now I mean where do you stand on this
debate
well that scared the life out of me I
you know I read that briefing and it's
terrifying but
um what happens at these meetings and
now by the way you know fully sympathize
with sooner he'll be exhausted it's
draining as well as exciting to be you
know in Washington in the white house
but quite often not much comes out of
them and this is just a briefing of
number 10 saying well we'd like to take
the lead and sooner we'll discuss this
with by No Doubt others will try and
take the lead on this um there will have
to be a coordinated effort at some point
but um the headline implies a kind of
sweeping Grandeur as sooner comes into
Washington say we're going to take the
lead but actually it shows that there
isn't a huge amount that's going to come
out of this meeting between the two of
them
um an aspiration for Brick to take the
lead fine
um but you know a few years ago there
was a talk of a trade deal with America
uh it's about 25
000 miles metaphorically from that
so let's come to you for this
um what do you make of what Pippa has
alleged here saying that Boris and
Carrie Johnson hosted a close friend who
helped plan their wedding overnight at
Checkers when a number of Kobe
restrictions were in place she says A
lady called Dixie Maloney a corporate
events organizer stayed at Checkers when
there was effectively a ban on people
who weren't part of households staying
overnight what'd you make of this
well they say that she was working for
them and therefore it was allowed under
the rules I think it just shows how
crazy those rules and regulations were
because I think if you had a reasonable
he met he made the rules up didn't he
exactly so that they claim uh that that
she was there under that she was trying
to be there that they checked all the
rules and it was okay for her to be
there
um I think the thing is it's a bit of a
gray area what the relationship with
this girl called Dixie why they all got
such strange names anyway Dixie
um uh uh what their relationship was
whether it was just purely work or
whether there was a crossover into
friends you know often in politics uh
that happens uh people work together and
then they become friends so I suppose if
you're in a situation where
um you've got some strange rules about
lockdown uh which are a little bit
indecipherable it's easy to to shade
into the gray but yes I mean this is
just I mean this is Peppers this is this
is an extension paper scoop when she
worked at the mirror
um it's more to do with uh it's more to
do with the sort of covered lockdown uh
partygate Scandal
um and it will just keep running and
running I think as more and more little
tip bits like this come out
okay we're going to move on because
we're tight on time tonight and we want
to have a look at how the Metro is
covering what's been an extraordinary
story for us here blowing up of this Dam
in Ukraine uh Steve the Metro's saying
floody Maniac having blown up Dan
Putin's next move could be to Target a
nuclear plant what'd you make of its
coverage
uh well it's deeply depressing and a
sign that this is going to go on and on
I've been uh at this press preview where
newspapers at times have carried reports
which suggested that Russia was in
Retreat perhaps faithfully and then you
get something like this uh which is you
know appalling on so many different
levels but it's not a sign of retreat
and
um you know the question is posed every
now and again and needs to be how is
this going to end how do Wars end
um and it's not at all clear and as you
say the suggestion as well as reporting
the consequences of the flooding of the
dam in effect
um the speculation of targeting nuclear
plants I mean it's it looks as if things
are gonna intensify
um and um it's not at all clear how this
is all going to end
and quick look at the Ft before we do
this in a bit more detail on the top of
the hour uh theft we've got the U.S
Edition rather than the UK Edition but a
fantastic picture of of New York City
and the skyline people we think are
probably doing some yoga or some sort
and of course the smoke High alerts smog
stifles New York we've had some
extraordinary pictures ourselves from
Mark Stone I mean talk about pollution
you wouldn't want to be there at the
moment Sarah would you
know this is the smoke from the
wildfires isn't it further north in
Canada no it looks awful it reminds me
of those pictures you used to see of
London in the 1950s
um when it was known as The Big Smoke
yeah I mean I'm very unpleasant
um apparently it's affecting Washington
as well so I hope Russia soon asked what
his mask
oh yes Steve a quick word I mean it
would be terrible to be there right now
and you can just imagine the health
effects I mean it's only one shot that
we had the sky was orange never seen
anything quite like it
yeah I mean amazing television pictures
aren't they because you know you could
convey right away how weird it is yeah
one breath and you think that's the
equivalent of knocking back 20 which is
Gore Watts or something you know it is
okay uh yeah well leave it there Steve
Richards and Sarah Vine thank you so
much for that